Sierra Leone's national symbol now
nothing more than a stump after 400
years freetown's Cotton Tree was finally
felled by a storm on Wednesday it's a
loss that the country's president has
described as leaving a gap in people's
hearts yes
[Music]
and one of the purpose of this way it
has served as a
according to Legend slaves who won their
freedom fighting on the British side of
the American war of independence prayed
under the tree when they arrived in West
Africa and founded Freetown it's since
adorned banknotes and stamps and has
become a place of prayer for the
residents of Sierra Leone's capital in
recent decades it's towered over a busy
roundabout near the national museum the
central post office and the country's
highest court it's a historic moment
because the country tree has been around
for more than 200 years and yesterday we
experienced a the end of this wonderful
and historic moment
the remains of the 70 meter coupon tree
will now be taken to Sierra Leone's
National Museum to be preserved and
remembered Alex beard Al Jazeera